ladies and gentlemen Tim Dylan is on
tour It's the final leg of the American
royalty tour Rochester New York New York
New York Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Houston
Texas San Diego California Detroit
Michigan Toronto Ontario Austin Texas
Brea California Columbus Ohio Bethlehem
Pennsylvania Washington DC Northfield
Ohio San Antonio Texas Dallas Texas
Atlanta Georgia St Louis Missouri
Indianapolis Indiana Boston
Massachusetts and then Foxwoods in
Connecticut go to Tim Dillan comedy.com
promo code fake Biz F A ke b i
z what tickets are on sale now tickets
are on sale now and then after this I'm
taking a nice long break so get the
tickets enjoy the show and then you'll
never see me for a while then I'll be
back 90 days later screaming about that
I'm kidding I'm taking a little bit of a
break these are the final markets that
we haven't done the hour in you're going
to love them
you're going to love the show it's a
great show we don't if you're for Israel
for Palestine no matter what you're
for you come on out kill each other at
the show you have a big fight at the
show you everybody fight at the show
I'll sit on stage and have a sandwich
good night ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the Tim Dylan show um I'm here happy
Halloween we are uh progressing we are
moving forward uh I have
on my head something called a I believe
a Shamong yeah and a and
a
uh
yamah I'm representing
both um and the Free Press which is
Barry
Weiss's even though she won't come on
the show because I am in Hamas that is
the one reason she will not come on we
have the Free Press
hat that we are displaying prominently
on the desk
and you know I
mean I just got out of the comedy store
with an amazing audience and with a
great
show and I I'll I'll let my mouth come
out a little bit here because I feel
like that helps with the audio even
though I I do like it up like this
right it sounds the same right it sounds
a little muffled what do you like about
it like this well because I like I
actually see the point now of you know
really getting into somebody's
eyes and the whole idea is that you
can't really understand a person until
you've looked into their eyes but no I
do I do probably to do the
show is a
little it's a little muffled we can do
this um and we have our yamaka
here for the for the Jews and we have
the Princess Diana bear as
well
um
you know uh I'll probably have to take
this off too my we my face is is very
blotchy so I put a lot of
uh some type of weird thing on it that
made it worse MH and I now I look Corps
likee and because I look very pale so I
I I wash it off and then instead of just
whatever recording it another time I had
my producer I said just fix me an
Islamic headdress which he was able to
do very quickly we here in Beverly Hills
it was not a problem able to do it
immediately um but I do think
unfortunately we will have to kind of
you know take it off and
then it's hard it's hard to God it's
tied in the back you got it is T it is
it is difficult it is difficult it is
difficult to to do these things and to
um to keep them going but we do we do we
have them all here for everyone we are
we
are everybody is you know I have a lot
of people have been very negative about
this war and I've been one of them and
I've realized that that's kind
of self-defeating to be negative about
this
conflict I think actually we
must actually with unironically
here look at some of the the benefits
of this and there are there are some
they're not obvious there's obvious
benefits to having an ice cream
sandwich or or bringing a sick friend
some chicken soup these are obvious
benefits but when it comes to a war of
civilizations or whatever is
happening you know but you know
everybody's like oh we're on the brink
of World War III I've said it a bunch we
are but here's the
deal we need this a little
bit we need we're coming out of a
pandemic we're out of it now but we have
a lot of economic
uncertainty we need a little bit of hey
we need a little bit of turbulence we do
we don't function really well without it
since 9/11 we've had it whether we've
manufactured it or it's happened
naturally we need a little bit of
turbulence turbulence makes the flight
go by a little faster it does because
you're a little scared and you're kind
of like and you're not thinking you're
just not watching the clock you're not
watching that you know the thing that
they give you the flight map where you
watch the the the flight make a very
slow
progress to where your final destination
is when you start getting rocked around
in the sky you don't look at the flight
map and then you're like oh we made some
time we need a little bit of turbulence
this is
actually I know a lot of people are
negative a lot of people are upset a lot
of people are rightfully concerned about
their own safety the safety of others
the safety of their family can we zoom
out can we Zoom the out for a
minute look at this in the
macro we need
it we need it we need the we need
destroyers in the sea we
need planes buzzing each
other we need to build some
weapons it's what we
do this is what we do it's who we are
and I think it's time that we embrace it
and stop
pretending that it isn't
good it has its
drawbacks substantial loss of
life is one of them I could be one of
the we don't know who gets it we don't
know who's going to get it we never knew
but in the macro
this is what our country does this is
what we've built a an arsenal of
Weaponry to
do this is why we have all these bases
this is why we have this Labyrinth of
intelligence agencies this is why we
have all this
stuff now you may not like it and I
might agree with you you might make a
lot of good points but no one cares
about your points and no one cares about
mine we are all passengers on a a voyage
we are
passengers on the V we are in we are in
coach some of us are in first class none
of us are in the cockpit none of us are
are landing This Plane none of us got it
off the ground we don't know where it's
going this is not an you could go on
Instagram you can go on uh I can't right
now because the Pizza Hut video which
they were not thrilled with I'm having a
little time out and I'm realizing the ER
of my way I'm sorry and I realize that y
y to the to Yum brands to the people at
yum
brands I am sorry that I implied in a
video that Pizza Hut supported
Hamas I apologize to the good people at
yum brands the people that poison are uh
citizens and our children the people at
yum brands whose job is to see how much
plastic they can legally put in ranch
dressing and how much saturated fat and
trans fat and sugar and all these things
they can cram into every morsel of of
food that they serve to children at Mall
food courts and uh Community College
food courts killing the people that they
serve the good people at yum brands I
apologize for implying even satirically
which it clearly was that Pizza Hut was
in any way in League with Hamas even
though Pizza Hut and Hamas are kind of
similar in many ways certainly Pizza Hut
and the Palestinians have some
similarities Pizza Hut's not running the
show we could admit that Pizza Hut's not
really happy with the way things have
gone the past 10 15 years let's admit
that mhm so I thought it was quite clear
that if anyone was going to come out and
endorse Hamas it would be Pizza Hut who
has it's been nothing they've done
nothing but lose ground to other better
funded you know expansionist operations
like Papa John's and dominoes and so I'm
in a little uh timeout over
there I got to give credit to where
credit is due I do respect Amy Schumer
for going out and speaking her piece you
may not like it you may not agree but
she is going out there and she is not
backing down and people are giving her a
lot of for what she's saying I
don't know what she's saying now because
I'm not on Instagram because of young
brands in their Infinite Wisdom who have
hit up the great people at meta and of
course are going at me but I respect
people that go balls to the wall and say
this is the way I feel and I don't care
if you don't like it and I got to say I
mean I'm probably not her favorite
person I don't know we've never had any
conflicts that are that you know huge we
I mean I've disagreed with things um but
I would say that I do you got to respect
when someone is in the public eye and is
going hard for the things that they feel
are right
and
true and what I'm saying about this War
and what I'm saying is that everybody
better enjoy it it's not going anywhere
you better get to like it you better
like it's you better figure out what
about it you
like it's like your stepmother no one
wants a step no one wants a step parent
I've said this before it's a horrible
thing for children to go through to have
a stranger come into your home and
simulate a a role no one loves a stepar
parent it's never happened never one
time and and and I don't mean that you
won't begrudgingly tolerate someone or
that you and that person can't have a
friendship like you would have with a
local librarian that you know what I'm
saying is deep love is hard with a
stepparent and and and but you better
but your father or mother loves that
person and you better figure it out and
this country likes War we like it and
we're going to and we're gonna maybe get
in with you because that's kind of what
we do and there's got to be a part of
you that just resigns yourself to it you
you you don't have to be on war footing
per se no one's asking you to to do
that's the good thing about America we
don't ask you to do it
Israel is asking their people to do it
all we ask you to do in this country is
eat there's something nice about that
we're on the brink we've been in Wars
forever I no one has even asked me or
any of my friends to do a sit up or run
around the track or learn how to fire a
gun or you know no one we are asked very
little where all we're asked to do is is
sit around and consume buy crap throw
on a charge card you know move in
with your brother and Charlotte and try
to get a job we can do whatever we we
don't have to make any sacrifices
there's enough people to do that when
they don't ask us to do that we're not
asked to do that nobody get not hello
yeah it's time to fight what time to
fight today
what do you mean the Ukraine what no
one's allowed to be gay what do you mean
you can't be trans if R in Russia and
they're GNA make you not be Trans in the
Ukraine yo I was sleeping you're GNA be
in a War now no one's saying
that no one knocks on your door and goes
hi do you understand that they don't
have a real housewives franchise in
qar no well you better get your
head blown off so that one day they
do that's cuz that's a lot of the
rationale we have now is that you know
but and I listen I'm not saying it's
it's it's sad for gay people in Guitar
although I did read an article that
there were some gay people guar they
were having a good time I don't know
what's happening I'm sure they're not
but there small groups of people that
are very sh about it seem to be okay my
point is that nobody asks you to
sacrifice anything in this country
uh for our lust for blood we have a Lust
For Blood and yet nobody really asked
you so you should really maybe not be
that mad about it now I know I just
spoke to a guy at The Comedy Store his
aunt was killed in a drone strike in
Gaza which is sad and by the way if
anyone wants to paraglide to my aunt's
house I have her address but the
point is how come everyone else gets her
ant killed um the point is this that is
sad but he didn't know her that well the
point is this I'm saying for a country
that goes to war as much as we do that
is always involved in something or other
we were in Afghanistan for like my
entire life for my whole life no one
even knew no one even knew they actually
stopped reporting it on the news nobody
even asked so my my thing is is this
you're not asked to do anything in
Israel they call up their reserves they
actually have to
fight there was this really sad story
about a kid in Maryland we're not going
to get it up put it in
post it is what it is just trust me I'm
not lying to you folks not making things
up here I don't have to every minute I
don't have to go to the article and
be he was a kid he's like 22 or whatever
he splits his time in Israel and America
the way I do it in in uh you know New
York and uh LA and Texas I travel around
the world and that is the World by the
way New York La in
Austin after this thing happened he goes
to Israel and he's killed immediately by
a Hezbollah rocket and it's tragic and
he's a hero because he believed in this
thing and he was a Soldier and I
respect the hell out of somebody like
that and in Israel you you
you have to you're that's your thing
everybody does I believe a mandatory two
years of military service in Israel and
then I believe you like kind of go into
the reserves they fight they are asked
to make a sacrifice in
America not
really right there's no draft no draft
yet there's never going to be a draft
there'll never be a draft in this
country there'll never be a draft in
this country there'll never be a draft
because I mean unless we are
completely besieged but then we have
weapons we have we we've invested what
we've done which was intelligent
actually we looked at our population and
said we better have good weapons we
better have great weapons because our
population with all due respect are
morbidly obese fentol addicts who commit
sex
crimes you know that's many of them not
all but a good amount of our population
are morbidly obese fentol addicts
committing sex
crimes those people are a liability now
why did how did they get there I don't
know we poison them all by you know
serving them paint chips and yum brands
and all their food they shove
down your throat and you know all of
this crap and every and we've lied to
them and we've poisoned the well with
the media and everything else and we've
confused people to the point where many
of them are walking around in a in a
Fugue State kind of they are an extreme
liability to have on the front lines of
any War the average American on the
front lines of any War they'll kill each
other they'll kill each other they will
not be an asset to the operation it is
much better with drones and it is much
better with technology now you're
looking at me but you're agreeing with
it you must agree with me here the front
lines of a war with an average American
right now would be a a
disaster the military does not want the
people they don't want them they've been
asked the government has asked the
military would you like a draft do you
want the citizenry they don't the
citizenry in America is two years to
killing each other you it's not
cohesive Russia there are emptying the
prisons so they can fight in the Ukraine
Russia has almost no prisoners left
because they keep opening the prisons
and letting all the prisoners just go
fight in the Ukraine and maybe we would
do something like that I I don't know
but I cannot see a draft happening in
America it just doesn't seem like it
would be
good for the uh like you know
cohesion I mean I mean could you imagine
like maybe some people would rise to the
occasion MH but a lot of PE people have
their phones out they'd be taking foot
like you can't just take the this
population and turn them into honorable
soldiers now you
can't you take them T them in honorable
soldiers now no you can't teachers are
like dating their
students I mean what are we doing here
we're going to turn every I'm I just
drove down the street there's
influencers with their with their tits
out there's car crashes because people
are swerving around these idiots you
can't turn them into loyal
honorable soldiers at the moment it's
not going to happen that's why if you go
out into the California desert we have
underground facilities with with the
Machinery of death we have
invested in the Machinery of death so
that that will do the job for us that's
the same that's got it's the same
reason we have the robot
cops coming into all the cities because
we've realized technology is going to be
the thing not people not people you're
you're it's not my
fat
Brethren my drug addicted I mean how
much medication is every American on
right that they'd be expected with in
the military they'd have seven pills
they need every day to just not kill the
person next to them they need three or
four pills to get out of the tent to
just go on about their day there is no
draft can you imagine
that Mr Sergeant has anyone seen my
Prozac it was next to the
zenx it's next to the
squil there'd be massive Pharmaceutical
operations to just get the people out of
the tent every morning get the gun in
their hand they have no here's one thing
we would have no problem killing
children there is benefits to a draft we
would have no qualms killing
children if if I I if we had to I mean
we would van it would be no problem to
kill them in our in our country we would
have no
conscience there'd be no moral qualms
about anything we had to do it would be
the simple fact of like could we do it
in the allotted amount of time would we
listen would we be organized that's the
worry that would be the worry like how
does this actually happen what is the
functionality of of drug
addicts who eat yum Brand's food all day
how do they so we not going to do that
America is not keen on us in the war
zone in the Battleground we don't even
try we've never even try like we are
basically like keep the people away let
the people do what they're designed to
do go to the mall go to the food place
get the food get your prescription go
home go do the phone scam go do
telemarketing scam the old people call
the old people tell them their roof is
get their credit card number you
know what I mean like that's what people
really in this country are meant to do
go to the call center go to the call
center get here's a list of people call
the people get their credit card numbers
or social security numbers Rob them this
is what people are designed to do not be
an honorable soldier in a
war no it's go to the call center here's
where you have lunch you have lunch at
Ranch one one you got a chicken and
cheese sandwich pretty good Ranch one
chicken and cheese is good cuz they have
the they have the long flat pickle that
vasic used to do the long flat pickle
the sandwich stacker Ranch one has a
really good chicken sandwich and then
you just call old people that's the
majority of the American economy is
calling old people that terrifying them
screaming at them telling them they
they're everything's there they're going
to lose everything but you have to give
me your you have to pay for this stuff
um I remember after Hurricane Sandy um
there was a group there was a call
center in Long Island where I knew a
comic who was working at it where their
job was to call old people and tell them
that the government FEMA had given them
too much money and they had over
improved their houses and FEMA wanted
some of it back this is true and and the
people in Long Island lined up to do it
because they're amoral they have no
morality so they would call now if there
was this is kind of a war we have the
best soldiers in the world at that war
the war of just calling an old person
and go hi um how are you is this Mrs
Donnelly yes now do you remember when
you got uh I believe it was $992,000
from FEMA to make improvements to your
house well yes I do it was very hard but
we did it yeah FEMA actually looked at
their records you only should have
gotten about
$60,000 you owe us
$30,000 literally they were doing that
to people and she goes what what are you
talking about you'll lose your house if
you don't come up with a payment plan
but this is how sick people th those
people that are willing to do that
they're willing to call elderly people
and demand money back you cannot put
them in a war zone do you understand you
can't put them in a situation where they
have we have not trained Americans to do
that we've trained
Americans in a war zone you have to just
not you you have to go like you know you
have to listen to the general and you
can't ask questions you got to listen to
your
superiors a Americans are not built like
that they're built to to not they they
will listen to people and they will
carry out orders with only if they can
identify their self-interest in it
immediately only if if Americans are
that because and I God the great Ray
come we've said it many many times and
I'm going to say it again it's why we
cannot have a draft we are a nation of
fat cowards and there is nothing where
it's okay to to be cowards or Andor it's
okay to be fat but there's nothing worse
do you do you know how demoralizing it
is to watch fat people run away from a
battle do you know how demoralizing it
would be on the world stage to watch fat
people abandon and go awall and run away
from a battle which they would do in
Mass if Americans cannot identify their
selfish if you want Americans to be in a
war you got to make it a business where
they can get money and real money you
have to like make it an entrepreneurial
activ it's not going to work if
Americans cannot identify the thing that
Israel's done brilliantly is
everything's like it's Israel it's it's
us they have a little ethnos State over
there meaning that I know that they're
like well there's some Arabs living
there peacefully too yeah it's primarily
about the Jews I and there's nothing
wrong with that but that's what it's
about so everybody there is like it's
for Israel
like my friends that are Israeli and
they're Jew it is Israel they go on
Birthright when they're young they hook
up with a chick they have fun they go
they love they have a great
relationship um to Israel because it is
they consider it like part of their home
and they will fight for it and they will
die for
it I like New Jersey you know what I
mean but you know let's just America we
we've not been
trained with that mentality like we're
all in it get we're not in it together
in America we have not
been that hasn't been uh we're not
really like H you
know Israelis truly believe that Israel
is their home and they're willing to die
for their home there's something very
beautiful about that very it's very old
school there's a lot of Honor there
Americans believe we're
here but we're here and we're all kind
of also competing with each
other and we also need to defeat other
people to have the good American
Experience like we need to kind of get
over on these people and we need to see
these people as a problem and what tends
to happen is we just don't have the same
experience as like Jewish people in the
state of Israel right like who are
really ready to fight and die for it
that's why people
will sacrifice everything and make the
great sacrifice for Israel but in
America that's just not I'm just
imagining like a draft and like some
like Christ Stephano calling me and he's
like what's up bro I I don't like this
I'm like yeah I don't I don't like e
what are we what he's like bro like I
love America but what's the deal with
this and I go yeah me too I got
I'm trying to buy like Trevor Noah's car
I where where do we got to go die like
it just isn't we here's the deal
countries make deals with
people the deal Israel made with its
citizens was like we've got this
beautiful paradise you're all a part of
and you're just you're born Jewish
you're in it but you got to sacrifice
for it okay America's deal with people
just kind of just like hey you're here
shut up a little bit shut up a little
bit don't don't don't ask too many
questions about why the news doesn't
really make sense don't ask why this is
what it is just kind of go with it let
us do what we do we play the songs we do
the stuff we'll do the football games we
do the fly over you show up it's all
good we're not going to really ask you
to go out and lay your life down for it
we're going to let people kill you in
our country that's going to happen
everyone has the right to kind of be
whoever they want here you can have a
gun you could kind of do whatever you
could go insane we're g to experiment on
some of you some of you are going to you
know wash out a controversial weird
programs are going to put you right back
we'll put you right back in general
population we're going to try to
brainwash some of you and experiments
and after that we're going to throw we
just keep it fun here it's going to be
fun yeah we're going to watch some of
the some of the people that wash out of
these controversial clment we just throw
them right back into the mall see how it
works and they can have guns and we'll
see what happens we're going to let
people call you and Rob you over the fun
if you're not slick there's going to be
guys telemarketing trying to convince
you that you need to pay for X Y and Z
it's it's a total like that's what we do
here you got to survive in America the
war is here the war is home for you and
we're going to open the borders up and
we're going to let everybody come in
because rich people want maids and
nannies and landscapers and like some
other people might come in they might
not be great but and if you live in a
bad neighborhood it might make things
worse we don't know we don't really know
we're going to bring drugs in because we
got a narco State on our border we don't
know how that happened but Mexico is a
narco State we can't do anything about
it it's just weird and there's all these
illicit streams of money that come out
of there that we're going to use to fund
Wars in other countries and that's going
to poison those countries against us and
then we're going to take in some of
those people and they're going to go to
college here with you and they might
lock you in the library it's just but
we're not going to ask you to go fight
in a war because the fact that we've
done all of these things has kind of
made everyone schizophrenic and not know
what the hell's happening we don't know
what this place is anymore Andor what we
are fighting for so it's very hard to
ask people to make the ultimate
sacrifice for this country because we've
kind of Poison the Well a little bit by
treating them all as lab rats like
people we kind of experiment on we go
we're just going to try a bunch of
out the American government does we're
just going to try a bunch of out
see what happens someone will make money
don't worry someone will get rich all of
the things that are hot we don't someone
will get rich someone will get rich
might be you but that's
why it's very difficult to ask people to
make a sacrifice so I know people are
getting angry about all of this death
and chaos and Carnage but just believe
you me I don't believe that they're
going to ask us to make any type of
great sacrifice it's just not what we do
it's not what we are about our job is to
to survive the war at
home the war that they keep bringing to
us the Battleground is here it's in the
inner cities you can see people walking
all over the place they're on fenel
they're on drugs the governor of
California is meeting with the president
of China the president of America's
talking about the Ukraine he's got a
speech about the Ukraine but on
Kensington Street in Philadelphia
Veterans who fought in our Wars are
dying on fenadol in front of
everybody so really what you see is
we're we're we're this is just a a
situation we've got a bunch of lab
brats and we're seeing what happens
let's see if they grow their fur back we
don't
know but they're not coming to us and
they're not they're we don't have to go
die somewhere else we've got good
machines to do that we've already got a
military of people that some of them are
very brave and Incredibly honorable some
of them just want to kill it doesn't
really matter either or it's all good
it's all works we've already got one we
got enough people and as things get
worse we'll probably get more people now
it's hot many of them are getting too
fat they're not happy that a lot of the
military is fat now or that you it's
harder and harder to get people in the
military because they're you know we
they have we have Google so people kind
of know what's going on Andor the fact
that they're trying to do military
recruitment videos with Dylan mulany
who's trying to explain to you how
important it is for you to go fight so
the people in the Ukraine can enjoy
budlight uh I don't know what what
whatever it is it's harder and harder to
get people into the military but they'll
get enough people in there you don't
have to worry they're not coming to you
your job is to die at home it's America
job's to die here at home in front of
your
family that's your job the economic
engine of a we didn't win World War II
Russian blood won it our industrial
power run it because that's what we're
good at we're good at making money
that's our thing so we don't need
anybody we need everybody here home at
the call center you got to go to the
call center now go to the call C it's
that's what it is that's why Bush after
911 said hey everybody it's time to go
shopping get out there and get a
panini press don't worry about it we're
going to figure it out we got enough
people to go there and kill we need
money we need gobs and gobs of money
bags and bags of duck tailes
gold so that we can keep making these
big uh
machines that will deliver death to
people and that you guys can stay home
you need to go to the call center now we
need to go to the call center that's
what you need to do that's the American
economy and of course I'm
oversimplifying it there's many types of
call centers but you know what I mean
that's the American economy you have to
do it your job is to die at home that's
what your job your job is to participate
in this
thing that we do this American
experiment which has gone completely off
the
rails but they don't want you honorably
fighting a war somewhere I mean that's
just not in the cards here that's not
what this place is designed for it's
just not what it's designed for it's not
they want you to call the CIA on your
neighborhood and vaccinate their kids so
that they can take them in away in the
middle of the night that is what this is
It's You should be a rat you should rat
on people people call people make sure
that you're willing to Dime on your
neighbors everybody's a threat here
report them to the government no
cohesion we don't want that no I'm an
honorable Soldier call the feds call
them on your
neighbor they're using charcoal that's
not regulated kill everybody that's we
we we don't want a Brotherhood of
honorable soldiers this is not Band of
Brothers this is called the CIA on your
neighbor because they're probably doing
something wrong it's just a different
thing I love chance I love Taking
Chances and I love when they work out so
does so many people in
America and it's fun I love sports I
love Taking Chances on sports right
isn't it amazing NBA fans the waight is
over basketball is back in draft King
sports book an official sports betting
partner of the NBA is celebrating with
an unbeatable offer new customers can
score $200 instantly in bonus bets for
throwing $5 on the NBA win or lose it
doesn't matter you'll start the season
with an instant dub and with DraftKings
parlays everyone's got a shot in even
bigger basketball wins at even bigger
basketball wins string together multiple
bets from the same game or build your
parlay across multiple games for a shot
at making your payday even
sweeter basketball is more fun when
you're in on the action download the
draftking sports
book app now download the draftking
sports book app now and use code Tim
Dylan do it new customers can get $200
in bonus bets instantly for betting just
$5 only on draftking Sportsbook with
code Tim Dyan the crown is yours
gambling problem call 1800 Gambler visit
ww. 1800 gambler. net New York call 8778
heny or text heny 46739 in Connecticut
help is available for problem gambling
call 888 78977 77 or visit
CCP g.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort
licy partner Gold Nugget Lake Charles La
21 plus age verifies by jurisdiction
voen n bonus bets expire 168 hours after
issuance C Sports book. draftkings.com
basketball for terms eligibility
eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible gaming resources
just go to the draftking Sportsbook app
now download it and use promo code Tim
Dylan we're you're America's fastest
growing Energy Shot the magic promise we
refund 100% no questions asked if anyone
doesn't like it clean energy natural
ingredients without exercise or amounts
of caffeine look at this little guy so
great magic mind I love it goes great
with your morning coffee or instead make
your one cup of coffee less the whole
day it actually tastes really good Joe
Rogan had it on his podcast the
Kardashians are drinking it some of the
best Surfers in the world COA Rothman
and Nate Florence talking about it on
their podcast Forbes calls it silicon
Valley's new morning
Elixir our goal is to make the best
beverage on the planet for creators and
we promise to do it the right way for
everyone involved even if it means going
above and beyond industry standards the
magic mind promise we promise to use
only the world's best suppliers to
require rigorous testing of every
ingredient sent to us for every
production run to readily provide
certificates of analysis for our
ingredients to anyone who requests them
to inspect every bottle of magic Mine by
hand and ATT test every batch of magic
mine we produce in a third party lab all
of my friends take this it's amazing and
I just started taking it I have so much
energy here's to achieving greatness one
shot at a time might be the best quote
of the
century maybe it
is we ship internationally in over 50
countries including Gaza they're going
to edit that
out
I love it I like it it's great it tastes
good this will get you through the day
it's great energy it's true I love it I
have so much energy I do stand up I do
this um I I ran uh 16 miles
today uh through the Gaza Strip on
this and you
know Israel people people there's more
people seem to be really into it we
don't don't have a Birthright we should
where should Americans you know where
should americ you know in eighth grade
we go to the White House you go to
Washington
DC I didn't go I didn't go to on the
Washington trip because I was like not
good in
school but I went to the seventh grade
trip you went to Boston this is our
version of Birthright let me tell you
about the Boston trip you go on a duck
tour it's a duck and the duck
is
amphibious meaning it can go in the
water and it can also ride on the
street they show you a couple of
buildings they tell you about the
Constitutional whatever it's just you
know here's the Constitutional
Convention 1776 a lot of that history is
in Philly but whatever who cares we're
in Boston you're on a duck you go to the
Holiday Inn there's a dance you eat this
is a Birthright in a there is
no you know like we don't have that
thing we don't have that thing that is
it would be nice if we did maybe one day
we'll get it back but the the government
is not really engineering that we don't
really want you to make sacrifices to
like like for Foreign Wars the
sacrifices you'll make are domestic
someone shot your kid
sorry someone po you know we D you half
of your family's insane half of them
have cancer because they live next to
Factory that we allowed to dump in
the thing that's what it is sorry
sorry but so don't be too upset I know
people are getting all upset about World
War II but I'll tell you right now you
will W until you're emoli in your house
by a Chinese nuke you will never be
asked to do anything you will World War
III will be the most entertaining thing
before you are emol in your house by a
Chinese nuke you will not have to do
anything you will be looking at your
treadmill on your couch when you're
vaporized no one will come to you and
ask you to do anything except maybe you
go to the call center we're still open
they'll call you and they'll tell you
they yeah but there's like a nuke
warning today we're still open and you
know what how beautiful it would be for
you to get nuked while you were calling
an elderly person with dementia trying
to get their credit card information as
you were calling an elderly person with
dementia trying to get their credit card
information it just the nuke sails and
it's just over and you just see the
beautiful glow outside the window of the
call center no one will ask you to suit
up and get your fat ass in a Top
Gun plane you can't fit in and fly over
to China no one's GNA ask you to do that
you so don't be
upset they'll either figure it out or
they won't we're very good at at coming
close to death in this country and not
fully going over it we're very good at
not fully going full Hell mode you know
but we'll see I don't know Israel maybe
reain it in a little bit Hamas released
the hostages maybe some progress there
we don't know but be rest assured
America's not going to really ask too
much of its citizens it knows
better it knows better the war is at
home the war in America will always be
at home and it's a war that you're lucky
to be part it's lucky you're lucky
because it's not the war the people in
Gaza are going through where they're
being killed all the time this war is
like between college kids are
fighting people are
angry people are chanting in the street
but it's there's not that much of a it's
not like you're surrounded by mass
death from politics you're surrounded by
Death from other things but not not from
politics yet so this is just the war at
home home the word home will be like
what do I post well I just don't know I
don't know what to post my silence has
been noticed by some of the people on
the
board God damn it that's the war at home
it's a it's a very first
world somewhat you
know kind of
emotional strategic War being fought by
upper middle class professionals that
are trying to dance around each other
that are participating knowingly in this
Kabuki theater of making each other feel
good but you're not without water you're
not without electricity you're not like
the people in Israel without their
children right for the most part this
just is an exercise in the futility of
opinions that's what it is it's an
exercise in the futility of opinions
everybody's got to have one immediately
even though they're pretty worthless and
they certainly don't move the needle on
either side but you got to have one and
you sit there and you talk to your
husband Frank Frank what do you think
about this well the Middle East well the
well
Frank now listen I gotta post something
on Facebook about the Jews what Frank
what do I say well you know the woman
who works next to me in the data
collection agency is Jewish and she's
going through everyone's social media
and if she doesn't see something she
likes she's saying we're Nazis and I'm
not a Nazi Frank so what do I
say or it's people that are like you
know trying to figure out the the the
real cool you know detached thing to say
some brilliant treaties on human's
nature and deep oh it's deep isn't it
it's deep it's deeper than that it's you
don't even you take your out it's
your one because it's not even
about what you think it's about it's so
many layers deeper than that it's deeper
than those Hamas tunnels baby it's so
deep it's so deep it feels so good it
hurts but it's the only way to get to
pleasure pain it hurts you want to be
tied up and vulnerable don't you you
want to be T I mean it's weird and it's
like you know but what it is is the
futility of it PS meaningless people
have no idea what they're talking about
they never do it's something that we all
have to do we all have to do it I get
paid to do it and hopefully some of the
things I say are at the very least
entertaining but it's the futility of op
it's people being like well and then the
letters oh the
letters signing the
letters Kate Blanchett and Alec
Baldwin I want to sign a letter it's me
OJ Simpson Caitlyn Janet can I sign a
I'm gonna write a letter as soon as they
let me back on Instagram I'm writing a
letter and it's going to be all the
celebrities that nobody wants Kevin
spacy OJ Simpson Tim Dylan Tanya Harding
and we're going to write a letter uh
demanding things that have nothing to do
with
this but it's all the letters
everybody's writing letters and here's
the letter we're signing the letter it
dare you it's signing a letter what is
the language of this letter going to be
well I don't know what are we suggesting
what are we insisting what are we going
to do who are we going to disenfranchise
let's fight let's fight about the
language of the letter the language of
the meaningless letter that we write and
send to President Biden who doesn't know
what letters are he doesn't know what
they are he's completely left the planet
but someone's going to go there's a
letter here there's a letter and you
need to read it why because Aquafina
signed it who what how who what where
how the celebrities are writing letters
are going back and
forth we demand this and we demand
that fif f f f I smell the blood of an
Englishman write the letter which letter
have you
signed silly silly silly Society silly
culture it's what it is we're gonna ask
them gon to ask all the letter writers
to suit up is that what we're going to
do folks everybody who's writing the
letters we're going to put them in the
paragliders or is that what we're going
to do I saw a guy paragliding in Malibu
the other day by the way and it's like
is this really the time you know you
know he looked at his paraglider on
Sunday and went God I know it's rough
but I have to do it it's who I am I got
to do some weird so sport to
show off my hot you know
B I feel like paragliders aren't even
hot they're just like wiry guys they got
bored jogging and they're like I just
want to paraglide and I I know it
doesn't look great now but I have to do
it but is that what we're going to do
we're going to take all these letter
writers and put them on destroyers in
the South Pacific is that what people
think it's not going to happen that's
what we're willing to do and we're
willing to sign a letter we've we you've
you've now
seen this is exactly a we're willing to
go we're willing to sign a letter or
we're willing to call the University and
go I'm taking my money out of it why are
you giving these plac your money anyway
how much tuition do these schools charge
40 50 60 70 grand a year more why do
they have these endowments of billions
of dollar what is that why what kind of
slush fund do these institutions have
and why take the money away so many of
of my you know friends have been taken
advantage of and they they they just
don't know how to really use a good Law
Firm I had a friend who injured herself
with a um shopping
cart and because it was not you know the
wheel it was all stuck and this is what
happens to people like the good people
of America go out to buy food at the
grocery store and and you know you got
to make sure that the card isn't you
know because I actually had a friend
named Scott who injured himself with a
shopping cart in a Home Depot parking
lot and I swear to God he won $50,000
because if this this is true he worked
at Home Depot for like two days and he
then injured himself with a shopping
cart he used to be a comedian he's from
Long Island doesn't matter here's what
I'm trying to say you need good
Advocates that's that you need people
that are going to advocate for you on
behalf of you no matter what happened if
you injure yourself with a shopping cart
you should be represented and you should
get full and fair compensation from the
company and
no matter what the injury is if you
sustain it you need to be compensated
for it that's why I think I
personally have a lot of faith in Morgan
and Morgan because they are helping the
people and they've been fighting for the
people for a very long time if they were
around during the time of
dinosaurs they would have been helping
you if if like you were like I could
imagine like of being in a a situation
where a
dinosaur injured you or a member of your
family and then like that then Morgan
and Morgan says no like we're gonna
fight Morgan and Morgan has over 100
offices Nationwide more than 800 lawyers
with over1 15 billion dollar recovered
for over 300,000 clients Morgan and
Morgan has a proven track record of
fighting to get you full and fair
compensation Morgan and Morgan has been
fighting for the people for for over 35
years submitting an injury claim with
Morgan and Morgan is so easy if you're
ever injured you can check out Morgan
and Morgan their fee is free unless they
win for more information go to forth
people.com Tim or dial pound law pound
529 from your cell phone that's F rthe
people.com or pound law pound 529 from
your cell this is a paid
advertisement Helix everyone that comes
and stays at my house in Long Island
goes what are those beds literally and
it's Helix they're also asking me
because they want them for free because
they're all
scum but I love Helix it's the best beds
I have um I love them I have the
midnight Deluxe I think or something but
I'm I'm telling you right now it's like
so comfortable and you take this quiz
and the quiz basically figures out what
kind of sleeper you are and they match
you with the perfect mattress shopping
for Mattress is terrible it's horrible
you're like laying on them in department
stores it's gross but with Helix you
take a quiz they figure out what you're
about what kind of mattress works best
for you they match you with a model it's
amazing they give you a 10 or 15E
warranty it's wild Helix has been
awarded the number one mattress picked
by GQ unwired Magazine it's even
recommended by multiple multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving your sleep Helix is offering
20% of off all mattress offers and two
free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com timd and use code Helix
partner2 this is their best offer yet
and it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now but that's what we're
willing to this is not a country people
that are just going to suit up it's not
what we do there are some Heroes here
and and you know God bless
you but for the most part let's be be
honest this is we we know what we're
willing to do we're willing to sign a
letter we'll strike if you th if if you
threaten us with
AI like if if if if actors think their
likeness is going to be taken and
reused we'll go on a
strike and we'll sit around and we'll
demand we'll pick it and we'll sign
letters you know and we'll be like don't
we shouldn't do but that's kind of where
ends here you know that's what we are
been trained to do and we'll do it it's
what it's what we do as Americans we're
we're we're willing to go so far this is
what we're willing to do willing to sign
the and you know people that signed that
letter thought it was a big deal you
know and when they got asked to sign
that letter oh my God I was even like
kind of like when I saw the I'm like I'm
not even in the group that's asked which
kind of pissed me off you know what I
mean I'm like I have one of the biggest
shows in the world you know I I i' I've
sold out World Tour all over and no one
not even no one call I don't get an
email M nothing and I saw it and I was
kind of like I get it but some of those
people don't need to be signing that
letter not everybody signing these
letters is A-list there's a lot of CN D
list people on those letters why I'll
sign a letter I will sign a letter I'm
gonna tell you that right now I'm no
coward I am no selfish coward I will
sign a letter
I'm not one of those out there I
will give an e signature to a letter
that's what I'm about I've always said
that I'm not going to go to war or basic
training or give any of my money but I
will sign a letter threaten me
with a good time and yet I'm never even
asked I'm never even asked to sign a
letter no one's even said to me
can you sign a letter but I would love
to sign it you know and you know when
the people signed that letter they
really felt like they did they go like
I'm signed a letter same one
that Jerry Seinfeld signed that's
[Music]
cool because that's what we're willing
to do and and and that's why you do have
to respect people in Israel that are
willing to go back and
fight you know what I mean nobody's in
this country is willing to make that
type of set you think Chrissy Tan's
gonna get in the
paraglider is Chrissy Teegan in the
paraglider she's just paragliding it's
not going to
happen go to the call center we'll tell
you when we need you when we need you
you're going to have to keep calling
elderly people with dementia you get
their credit card numers of Social
Security you take their house you steal
it from them then you give it to someone
else and that person buys it they pay
way too much for it then they're
you keep calling them you get them
second mortgages and credit cards you
mire them in debt you put them you put
them on the wheel put them on the
wheel go go to the call center that's
where we need you sign the letter cuz if
you're not working in the call center
you you're signing the letter you're in
the Upper Crust you're either in a call
center like a little rat with your head
on the phone going hello is this Mrs
matui hey it's Barry how are you doing
can I tell you about a program we have
to consolidate you like you're either
that or you're sitting at home in Malibu
and you're like can you read the letter
to me France
what does it say well sign it we must we
must bring an end to this hurt this hurt
is horrible we must bring an end why
does she do the avocado like that I'm
briti I'm not even British but I talk
like this because I'm very rich in
America many women in America will start
to talk like this even though they're
not British um but that's what it is and
that's why that's why I think it's an
attitude adjustment it's an attitude
adjustment at attitude adjustment this
is not seen as a neeg it's Halloween
it's fun it's sexy time everybody's
going to be fine or we won't but the
point is this stop looking at all this
negatively this is kind of our
thing this is kind of our thing just
sign the letter or go to the call center
it's all going to be
okay don't
start trying right now at this point in
your life to have
honor do you know why they tell people
like in their 70s or 80s to not quit
smoking because at a certain point you
just the bile that comes out of your
system at the end isn't worth it because
it's just black Gunk you cough up and
stuff you know basically it's just like
maybe they'll tell you to cut down but
it is what the it is what are you
going to do quit smoking at 80 and and
do be a gymnast it's that's you start
doing marathons that's not what
it is at the end the bile the gunk the
poison that you cough up out of your
body kills it if you quit smoking so you
can't okay so at the end of the
Empire if you discover
honor you you better be very careful how
you do it because it's going to cause
you to cough up a lot of bile and it
might just kill you so be very
careful go to the call center get on the
phone sign the letter have a cup of
coffee nod to the person in Starbuck
very sad wish it was better sorry about
that
brighter days ahead let's hope everybody
gets their thinking cap on
cooler heads prevail what a great saying
how American I hope cooler heads prevail
go to the backyard have a
cocktail you're not dead yet cooler
heads
prevail tell your kids that everything's
fine because as of now it is don't start
going crazy we don't need a bunch of
Colonel curtes running around that's not
your job your job is not to lead some
type of
sectarian Revolution here your job is to
come up with 10 5 to 10 phrases you
repeat at nauseum while you drink your
flavored coffee amoretto French vanilla
hazelnut is that called that's a creamer
called Italian h holiday cookie
ooh terrible times hope cooler heads
prevail yeah hope things don't spin out
of
control things over there are tough come
up with the phrases you repeat the at
nauseum you get in your car you get in
your car it'll be okay I promise you
nobody's going to knock on your door and
ask you to make the great sacrifice it's
not the way that you have been built we
have not engineered this
experiment um around the idea of
selflessness can we say that is it fair
to say that kids is it fair to say that
we've not engineered the American
experiment around
selflessness that's not what we're about
is it no we are about us your stance in
everything is you
you cooler heads prevail have a cup of
coffee my friend's mother she knew
someone over there God so tough hits
close to home that's a good one go hits
close to home hits close to home cooler
heads hopefully cooler heads prevail you
know but don't get to down and don't
Center yourself do what you need to do
I'm speaking of of course to uh most
Americans you know the ones that are not
in Hamas and NYU or you know the ones
that are not in the IDF I'm speaking to
the people who are hoping that uh all of
this ends in a positive way um but don't
freak out don't
panic you will not die probably from
terrorism you'll die because your
government is engineering all kinds of
fun booby traps like the house at home
alone for your life it's not going to be
foreign terrorist it would shock me if
uh people I know started getting killed
by Foreign terrorists I'm not saying
it's impossible I'm not saying it's
impossible what I'm saying is
statistically it probably won't happen
so don't get too
upset it's
okay figure out your pose
huddle huddle with people and say Here's
a good one here's a I'll give you a free
one as a mother even if you're not a
mother even if you're not a mother this
is what you should write as a
mother it breaks my
heart to see children
killed it's terrible
and then under that
right I've been
using some new products in my hair many
people have asked how I have had such a
natural shine and free color and free
flowing hair I have been using products
from this new Corporation that's been
sending me them and I will send you some
for free as well as a mother who said
about dead children I will take 15%
off the money that you would usually
have to pay for these hair products
where people keep stopping me in the
street and going God your hair it has a
glow they forget about the dead kids
when they see my hair cuz it flows yet
it has structure and form but yet it's
glowing because I'm a mother and I'm sad
seeing dead children I will take
15% off your order if you act
now and then after that right I hope
cooler
heads prevail happy Halloween everyone
goodbye